[Music]
and no for justice news I'm gonna buy em
love J okay a guy cooking smelly food in
Italy is now a crime all poor Asian
people what about like the goat cheese
stuff that's kind of smelly and then
smelliest checked it and by the way
parmesan smells like straight but fungus
she smells like [ __ ] sweat dude but
it tastes delicious it smells like
locker room to me I feel like this is a
straight attack on Taiwanese people and
their stinky tofu and I don't appreciate
it you think Italians I stinky tofu
because they like the stink too or not
no because that's a very different thing
from cheese stink oh yeah let me ask you
something your voice is just as at all
you've been to both Italian and you've
been to both fresh have you two done
that
yes Italian and French yep which food is
most stinky fresh or Mario Brothers I
think it depends on the dish yeah I
don't think it's the entire category do
Italians eat weird [ __ ] like the French
do it's weird for an American
perspective so like you cannot we're for
me
I'm just saying weird or American
hamburger eaters yeah so a regular
American they don't really want to see
the animal in Soul form but in in Italy
they'll be pizza with like baby octopus
all over and then a kid with the Valerie
like it's bomb but from American
perspective you don't want to see the
whole animal and don't you think them
out they want to see circle calamari
they don't want to see baby octopus all
the time you know the first time I saw
calamari like in full-form
on a pizza
people here are [ __ ] afraid of
everything they just want mac and cheese
all day yeah hey did you know in Canada
they're called kraft dinner for mac and
cheese yeah I like it cheap one - I'm
[ __ ] like low-class
oh yeah we know I get a choice between
the [ __ ] Velveeta cheese s mac and
cheese with the fake ass yellow versus a
nice fresh one with like real chunks of
cheese and all that hands down I'm going
for the cheapy with a powdered cheese
the powdered cheese when I only like it
because my grandma used to make it with
ground beef like I'm better go ahead it
was like a hamburger helper so it was
pretty [ __ ] good you can make mac and
cheese in the rice pot I don't know you
look good up there
yeah you could so there has been this
long-running battle between neighbors in
an apartment block and so there's a like
apartment building I guess I'm going to
find a legal fight why there was these
residents that kept complaining about a
married couple in their building that
kept cooking up a lot of rich pastas and
pretty nice tea which is mixed fried
seafood dish that's like super popular
in Iliad I shall [ __ ] bomb it does
I'm salivating yeah well thank you Miss
B so this dish is as beloved to Italians
as fish and chips are to the British as
hamburgers and fries are to the American
oh so if it's that common then why do
people go - Spanky apparently this
couple would constantly cook up really
smelly [ __ ] to the point where that's
just [ __ ] juice just kidding thank you
so there is a life the odors were so
pungent - a lot of these neighbors it
seemed as if the couple's kitchen was in
their own apartment Wow
Ginny blames apartment is yeah this is a
ventilation ventilation side one of the
neighbors that were complaining while
the cover
[ __ ] [ __ ] the cup always cooking
anything like my whole apartment became
impregnated with the smell of pasta
softened my machine is so delicious
I don't like impregnating any bury your
own quite another personal vegetarian
because I could see that like my mom in
Italy because my mom said she's a
vegetarian any smell of cooked meat
crosses her out he's not used to that
like animals smell how should i used to
distill around her still not used to it
laughs she walks by KFC it's like it
throws her off it's like smelling like
someone's aren't ya common buy a house
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] of marinara so
there's a couple like the neighbor is
just a couple of two quarts and in that
first quart they were found guilty of
antisocial behavior where a bug I would
be charged all the [ __ ] time did the
judge taste the couple's cooking yeah I
don't know exhibit a you know what
Mickey there just make you [ __ ]
dinner
everybody share the right to make dinner
it's not like she's taking a [ __ ] and
throwing it out of her apartment window
and what if it does smell like that like
she's ignition then I'll come over to
eat this and that's a smells work beyond
the limits of tolerability what is
making it stink so much though the heavy
sauce in the seafood inches well that
sounds amazing though you know I agreed
that slowly automated smells for myself
yeah so then the couple ended up
appealing that first court and they went
to a higher court that court found them
guilty as well so then maybe I'm like my
decisions then I went to the highest
court or the Pope no it's called the
Court of Cassation
castrations don't cut off the dick if
you're wrong on this one right there in
that court they still found them guilty
and they even came up with the term for
their offense which is called ol
effector molestation
what molesting the no food the olfactory
tradition that's [ __ ] crazy well Joe
I know that you're the type of dude
that's very affected by smells so like
even though you hear the description
just think of it as like you're smelling
stinky toes all the time
what [ __ ] shoot myself yes because
now you've been to Taiwan you know
exactly what I'm talking about
I know I still don't understand how
couples can feed [ __ ] bricks to each
other in that country it doesn't make
sense to me
cuz it was nasty here right you remember
the smell here it's [ __ ] beautiful
here in Taiwan it's like somebody bright
when you smell it take the overlay
provider and then you and I went over
there it is like this hi honey wonderful
you would leave for me like yeah they
link our mission to in the ether it
smells like someone [ __ ] in the paper
bag and you go and then it's like it's
fine because it tastes alright like it's
a little bit sour but I can do the taste
but then it's not until you go like this
you know yungang cool and you're like
good at it just take it a little bit but
I look at this guy [ __ ] it stomachs
rumbling I can go you [ __ ] monster I
taste the air when you walk through yeah
it's like a mist of [ __ ] it's like
someone crop-dusted the air with spark
and you walk into like a [ __ ] agent
orange zone good when I see like a
stinky tofu hawker stall all I see is
this big turd with eyeballs are smiles
hi guys like this hey hot yeah Oh mr.
dookey you want to eat some [ __ ] yeah oh
my I am NOT a fly they're saying that in
Italy disputes over cooking smells are
frequent in apartment building
oh it's frequent all over the place yeah
I thought Italians just like fight a lot
because they are part of the mob right I
don't know if that's in Edo there's like
a lot of gang rivalries right that's in
Italy the Luigi's Diana Mario in the
Mario's in the castle ona's and then the
Pizza Hut and in the East Coast
AHA says hotels [ __ ] Mexican the
Domino's in the Papa John's and they're
all battling it out for supremacy in
Milan
yeah but they're saying that people that
dispute over this because there's even a
lawyer who specializes in quarrels
between neighbors I like someone
normal yes lawyer saying that some
clients even claim compensation for
having to move their residents and an
others claim that they have suffered
depression even psychological trauma
from the cooking odor I get knows like I
could wake up every morning to somebody
cooking a farm ass breakfast like see
you Thomas no no that's their button
Callie an ingredients don't have stinky
tofu smell but the truth of you were
just talking about that's true I don't
know where arson she closes the IRA
thought to that was when we were in no
the suit repeated uh it wasn't such a
Switzerland that was and we heard that
the thing to get is Maryland oil in
Lucerne Switzerland is to get fondue
like that's their [ __ ] so I if I'm in
Switzerland I got to get some
[ __ ] fondue and that's like
food you dip it in cheese and whatever
and then we went into the store as soon
as I opened that you felt like foot
I got [ __ ] punch line it up throw
line I love you I love think you Topher
right but when I open the door I'm like
babe I can't you here I almost usual am
i honest we could do this no I thought I
was I cannot eat here I'm so sorry you
know why it smells like feet
you know why cheese it's the same
[ __ ] bacteria and yummy in your toe
jam yeah you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] in
between your [ __ ] nail yeah clearly
[ __ ] on you smell it that's the same
bacteria as cheese go fight back like
you know and you know what is hello you
scrape I said how you put up a top of
your mouth no joke that's the same metal
on their bacteria as chief that's why it
smells the same I don't think it's worse
in Taiwan it could be the same for Italy
which was the same thing in Lucerne
was it was human like the restaurant was
it well-ventilated a cold arm I don't
have to heat it up yeah it was warm and
the heater was up and it just felt like
you fell on an episode of I think it was
[ __ ] that's delicious but it was the
same thing when to a cheese store the
guy gagged you know he likes cheese I
never thought I can throw up on an empty
stomach
oh the first time it was on that
crowd so if you would wake up to that
kind of smell would you through your
knavery no I'd be violet I don't even
want to have to go through the [ __ ]
court [ __ ] cuz I know that's it's going
to drag it all along I'm just moving I
don't give a [ __ ] but what have you got
the apartment oh my gosh that's a
different you gotta fight for your right
to stayin I'm a bunch of managers both
other directions
I'm gonna get a [ __ ] building chief
well from the building construction of
this place that can even block a smell
I'm pretty sure you'll keep down the
whole building or I could just eat their
dinner every day and try to get used to
it or am I just put mothballs it or oh
my god or I'll just melt it dinner yeah
you like that yeah so the couple that
was found guilty they have to pay a fine
of two thousand euros Wow come on that
is a lot for snow for Olaf after Louis I
wish we could have that because there's
a lot of people that I know that I would
sue them for all the fact of molestation
alright I'm sorry you forgot the way I
thought you were speaking on olfactory
all factors most actually I think they
could do that cuz it's like mainly one
culture one group right you can't really
do that in a country that has so many
different ethnicities oh yeah they're
saying that the the complaints actually
have been rising because of immigrants
coming into the country increasing their
ethnic yeah because it's hard you know a
place like America we have so many
different cultures we'll be fighting all
day all [ __ ] day your food stinking
your food sticky no Moscow smash
nickyloo stinking every [ __ ] day if
somebody else [ __ ] different cultures
food stinky even within the culture of
[ __ ] I wonder if you sue somebody for
having really really bad breath well I
mean that halitosis I know a man was a
very very nice man and I very much
appreciate his company I apologize not
I've never but every time he sees me
he'll is it what's up man how you doing
me put his arm around me and have a
conversation like this and I got to
smell that [ __ ] and then literally my
pupils dilate and then my I like it
it's like Aunt Eller ptosis oh yeah it
literally is I don't know how to tell
her you probably can it could be a
condition oh my heart of stealing's the
maybe he does that sounds like ltos
suicidal you can't really cure that
might be something a stomach or you
should probably honestly just start
doing sign language they put his pretty
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] a yeah why does it
call what ptosis halitosis halitosis
yeah it just smells like halitosis yeah
hella your breath is keratosis
hello amount of people do you want to
contact me and everybody else you see go
ahead and check the description box
below and follow our social medias is
the Grahams and Twitter's for more
videos click up there baby
[Music]